you were there for what I believe is one
of the most bizarre moments in American
political campaign history Trump had a
Super Tuesday press conference and you
attended and Trump was trying to respond
to the fact that he'd been accused I
think by MIT Romney of having fake
products that didn't really exist
anymore and so he started bringing out
all his products and the whole thing
turned into an infomercial all of us
watching it I remember this very clearly
he brought out here you can see closing
on that and you'll see that he brought
out his wine his steaks and his Trump
water and you said that it was such a
strange moment because you were able to
walk up to them afterwards is that right
I actually had fun time writing this
part of the book it was really funny so
that Mitt Romney had gone after him in
this epic speech that he gave calling
him a fraud and a fake and of and very
very not smart and Donald Trump
responded in this press conference he
was winning a bunch of states on Super
Tuesday and he brought out Trump steaks
Trump wines Trump magazine and Trump
water mm-hmm but upon closer inspection
Trump steaks were actually Bush brothers
steaks from Palm Beach down the road Rob
didn't take the wrapper they didn't take
the writers off that rappers were there
and I would have taken a second to
switch the reporters walked into first
of all they were guarded by Secret
Service I don't know why but reporters
were at one point able to guard steaks
steaks need to be guarded at all time
there was there was they were not Trump
steaks the water was was bottled by
Village Springs bottling plant with a
Trump label on it the magazine that he
showed was the same customizable content
that but the best was the wine it said
Trump wine on the label Trump winery and
if you go to the Trump winery website
you'll notice that there's a little
disclaimer that says Trump winery is
solely I'm paraphrasing owned by Eric
Trump and has absolutely nothing to do
with Donald J Trump
so all of the things we're just easily
fact-checked before he got up to take
the stage but regardless of that and
these were you know spreading around
social media like wildfire regardless of
that he came out and he talked it up as
if as if nobody as if no one had eyes in
the room well it's his gift you know it
really is in a weird way is is it he
does have he does have certain gifts and
one of them is to just walk out there
and say yes I made this and they have
proof that no here's a photograph of
someone else making it ten minutes ago
that's bull I made it and he just goes
with it and it it's worked for him well
he certainly went with it that day yeah
you